about sampling organize Thanks so when
we talk about lower bounds we usually
mean over bounds for computing a
function on a given input this talk is
going to be about a different type of
lower bounds which I'm going to call
same thing lower bounds okay so here the
setup is that you have some distribution
in mind and you want to know how
difficult it is to sample that
distribution say just given random bits
there's many reasons so I think this is
a worthwhile mathematics it's often
common as if you have a different if
you're difficult problem that you cannot
solve you can try to solve a half the
problem so in general this thing is a
harder thing to understand because there
is many non-trivial ways in which you
can sample the situation I'm gonna give
you two examples of death there's been a
fair amount of papers until now some
connections have been established to
other areas but generally still
uncharted direction and I'm gonna give
you a bunch of open problems and just
want to touch on a couple of connections
so someone did some of the ideas and and
results that were developed here which
he used in the to source extractors
breakthrough by shadow body and Zukerman
and the later more specifically in the
titanium by Bernard Doran and - MA and
there is a connection to data structure
lower bounds which I'm going to touch on
later in this talk but I think it
doesn't it does not yet given very
strong bounds
okay so the back of this talk is going
to be about AC 0 but before that I'm
gonna mention a couple of simple
problems on decision trees okay because
I want to give you a sense of the
breadth of problems the techniques in
this area let's start with the problem
what trees so here I just want to simple
Heming slices okay so let's say that s
is the uniform distribution of an M bits
that will Hamming weight 1/2 and I want
to sample this distribution via a
function that map's some into things of
Benevento
to end this and each output bit of this
function is a small depth decision tree
in uniform bits x so the depth of this
mystery is this I'm going to call it for
depth the forest because it contains
several trees so we hope to simply sing
exactly but the heat but the you may ask
how far do you have to be from this
distribution and we measure distance in
terms of statistical distance between
the distribution as the target
exhibitionists and the output of F on a
uniform input X okay so the statistical
distance is a natural notion bastante
distributions which is written here so
it's how well test again tele2
distribution it's at the maximum
velocity of the sense that the one
solution
cleansing t minus the other one landing
t it's Rama within a zero and one okay
so that identical is zero if they are
disjoint supports you can get very close
to one so there is an argument they can
give a lower bound of 1 over truly
through the led
I'm just going to sketch it in words so
how do you prove this thing well let's
look at the ten bits of the distribution
okay so here this 10 bits are very close
to uniform can know exactly what very
close so this ought to be very close to
look to uniform in F okay if they're not
them because their sample by is not the
tree they must have a distance from your
home which is a twister this which is
much bigger than that of s and so you
get this lower bound otherwise every 10
bits exactly uniform and then you can
apply central limit theorem for bonded
independence in particular and take
concentration to argue that the Hamming
weight of this is unlikely to be exactly
n over 2 so at least you had some
buzzwords what goes on there you can ask
about rubber bands actually you can
reinterpret
some nice
works on switching networks about my and
other people to show that just with that
throw game even gets very close to this
distribution okay you actually simulate
a switching Network with such trees and
so an open question another question is
what is this quantity
okay so even for constant depth can you
prove that you know for that ten at this
distance it reads 1/2 okay this question
is actually connected to some questions
in the last lecture of storing sets okay
I'm gonna say too much weight body if
you can prove some very strong bounds
here for some variance of this question
you actually get some rebounds for the
rest our shop problem of stolen sets I
want to mention another simple question
and that's the question of storing
permutations so let's say pi is the
uniform permutation of the elements from
1 to n ok so just think of an array of
elements each element is within a
warning and a limitation and I want to
simplify again by a decision tree forest
so now each query of the tree will be an
element within a 1 n so the children of
each node are n was supposed to - and
it's not even known what the sophistical
distance if that she have death - so
each tree here just makes one probe -
uniform bits and then based on that it's
gonna make another province when I put
the value within a warnin and this whole
thing should be very close should be
maybe close to uniform illumination or
not so if you could prove our boundary
statistical distance designation to the
restriction that approaches one you will
get a lower bound for storing
permutations in the structure Kumada
this ones are known for a new adaptive
trees but even if you make a - adaptive
probes are not programmed so
so ii will just give you a lower bound
afford to sell probes so which is
unknown so it's consistent with a
twisted my knowledge that you can store
translation with zero loss in space and
enter each query with two probes I don't
know how to disprove is that the best
upper bound is like la ganancia I'm
gonna give you a than this talk very
nice I think upper bound for up for it
is zero for a simple implementations
okay so now I'm gonna switch to AC 0
doorway we'll come back to Trista for
some lemmas and when I draw these
circuits with the input X up top and the
output Y at the bottom and typically the
output will be will be more than one bit
abuse on sampling distributions so
although the circuits cannot compute
parity they can do something which is
almost as good they can pretend to be
computing parity they can generate
input-output pairs of the père de
functions and this is something which
was pointed out by Baba and bopanna and
gregarious three years ago and it's a
simple construction that actually even
though over any group okay so I just see
exactly what I mean so I claim that
there's a function the Maps just n bits
2 n plus 1 bits that's this is 0 in fact
it was just locality to within in the
second and the output distribution of F
over a uniform input will be exactly the
distribution y comma para y4y a uniform
the input ok so it's exactly generating
a uniform in put together with parody
and you can imagine just send up a 9
site that telescopic you get J so here
is the input the first output width will
just be X 1 the second output bit is
going to be X 1 X 4 X to the third is
gonna be X 2 X 4 X a and so on up to yn
these end up to debates are come
the uniform as you can check but resting
is that if you exert them you just said
just get X n so we just up put the party
in clear yeah so this actually achieves
statistical distance 0 you may think
well okay so it's this thing you know so
whatever what she even do a little bit
more so in packets one hour we were able
to show that the beam a sample why in
the part of a why so it's a little bit
more complicated oh it's a similar idea
so you build on the on the previous
result something which I find quite
exciting actually it's a very different
concept which I'll show you in a second
that you can send popery mutations in a
zero so zero can sample something which
is very close to a uniform permutation
of n elements and this thing has to have
some small error because the pressures
another power of two you can use this
result to even do other things like you
can sample for example input-output
pairs of any symmetric function so you
have s is zero circuits which can
generate a uniform X unit from Y
together with its majority okay with
something which is I find much less
obvious than the party example this
thing is going to use that and so it
inherits this this server but it's
conceivable that you could do this thing
with either 0 so as an open question for
you is this
so can you sample why majority why
exactly 0 and I think it's something
that that you can attack you know
tonight without any background besides
so what you have I think is people just
have no idea do probe these things so I
think it's consuming my baby was you
because the error here is actually of
the zpp type so even not to make a
mistake so conditioned on a small event
that you can recognize in this is 0 it
would separate that definition so if
there was a way somehow to recognize the
event and just in the case that massage
with the probabilities and make
everything fit nice you get error 0 yeah
but I try for awhile and I can do it
to me a lot
III don't know you know I don't
yeah I don't know this result I think
yeah the company and this spectacular
okay so I want to tell you this is there
anyone here who knows this thing a few
nations in this is from the nineties so
I'm not aware they be inside them does
anyone who knows it so if if you haven't
see that I think you like it I mean okay
so you can find a streamlined expedition
you find a streamline exposition in my
paper they do it in the context of
pyramids and so on okay so so what are
we doing we want to simple a vector of n
elements which are the permutations okay
so just a better way each end is going
to be an element within one and so the
basic idea is to start throwing okay so
then I have the numbers within one and
then a we're going to place them in the
array every one to n uniformly random
okay let's start with that so here's my
elements this thing are not random now
okay so it's not just the fixed element
two one two three four five I'm using my
random inputs okay in the zero to find
the random locations in a target array
okay present at this thing can be done
this is zero so if there is no
correlations then I'm done right then
this thing is exactly by symmetry
permutation of course there would be
collisions righteous if you throw em
things into n slots there will be
collision so some slots are gonna be
empty some source will be overcrowded
and gets on this thing is a problem so
what you can do well okay so let's get
some room okay so it's self sampling
itself throwing darts into Anschluss
let's throw that into em
for him much bigger than like n square
to enlarge it today and now you know
there's gonna be you know collisions
okay and I just need to remove the the
empty slots you said that they all is
exponential exponent what's the arrow
well okay so the arrow you know you can
make em to be a square and the arrow
with big sponsor is more than and cube
so I mean the chance of a collision
would be it's the edge I just need to
remove the slots here okay you want the
slots no that's impossible
right you're getting worse so that will
mean that we took place five at location
which which is I know how many non empty
slots you have here which is impossible
counting zero the key insight is the
next one which is I'm gonna think oh
conditioning a different way of a funny
thing really fascinating so I'm gonna
throw that in exactly the same way it is
described but I'm gonna think of a
probationary cycle format okay so second
form is just the a familiar one and the
cycles are gonna be written in a
specific way so each cycle is going to
start with a list element in the cycle
and the list elements are gonna be
sorted so here with two three so two
will be the list element so another the
cycle you know is 2 3 3 1 so this has to
be next cycle and what we need to do now
is to be able to compute the next
element in a cycle in a 0 there wher put
the foundation and this thing can be
done because you can identify in a 2-0
the beginning of cycles well that the
work the beginning of the cycle is
element which is smaller than against
that that comes before okay so one now
is the beginning of a cycle once you
know that it's easy to find the drags
point you know if you're a beginning
if you're not close to a beginning you
just go forward otherwise you go you go
back to the previous one
okay so now you can find the next one I
even just I put that information for you
same four conditions in so condition on
no collisions yes so if you have a
collision then your collision then you
just abort but you can recognize if your
collisions are not there so you cannot
do something with that each permutation
is so by symmetry so yeah you can verify
that it's yeah so you have to verify
that imposing this this doesn't yes but
you can verify that each cycle will have
its illicit element first and yoga right
cycles where the the one which has the
top list element among both cycles it
comes first so so here I have to write
down two three two two three first and
again I to put and to put a 1 by 4 okay
I cannot run with the arrow around
[Music]
format is justice spring array of
elements from 1 to N so given this the
another step to find so then to feel so
the position one of the array would be 5
so it is even going to look for the next
element the position 5 would be 4 and so
on yes I realize that all right so these
are google explains the the white seed
people to prove lower bounds let's see
what you cannot do in 0
okay so what role bounds state approves
so one over bound that were shown first
one actually was for sampling error
correcting codes this is in a paper with
sugar and then it was improved by back
in period so and gravity in a way which
I which shall be mentioned so here you
have a good binary or crap encode the
know as symbolically good then let's say
Z is a uniform distribution of our code
words I said that Vanessa zero circuit
which you know takes some input bits and
put a string of n bits then you go show
that the statistical distance within za
uniform code word and the upper
distribution the circuit is
exponentially close to one in the
original table we had Pournami liberals
to one and then with some method about
deviation bounds for Simone de forest
back in biasing right that should
improve the true exponential so this
result you know gives a very strong
bounds like it's exponentially goes to
one but it's really tailored for four
coats okay it doesn't apply to added
dispersion in particular it doesn't
apply to things like input-output pairs
of boolean functions okay
so later it was possible to get robots
events for this input output pairs day
so it was shown that if F is a boolean
function which is a bit block extractor
so it's an extractor for a type of
source which I'm gonna call a bit block
which I'll show in a second some things
that that we know how to how to
construct it's not important now then it
is xerokynos simple employed pipette
pairs of the of dysfunction such the
statistical existence is bigger than
than zero and i recently we improved
this result to something very close to
help okay so for the same function it's
possible to show that
the statistical distance will be super
anomaly close to 1/2 so 1/2 is the best
that you can hope for because either a
uniform and Y and 0 unit from Y and one
will have statistical distance 1/2 so
this thing this gives a function that
you cannot compute much better than
tossing a coin even if you can sample
the input yourself ok something which
wasn't known sir could get to sample the
inputs and it still cannot compute the
function much better than tossing a coin
okay so in the rest of this talk I'll
tell you some the techniques that go
into this the students actually started
with the first and then the second one
builds on the on the first so for the
first result the main theorem is this
one is a characterization of
distributions that you can sample in s0
and that have high mean entropy so the
mean entropy of the distribution is just
it's the worst case notion event to be
supposed to average case and notion
inertial and to be the meant with is at
least k if every string has mass at most
romano's scale so the theorem it said
that if you have any circuit whose upper
distribution has meant to be at risk'
then the upper distribution on the
circuit is very close to a convex
combination of much simpler sources so
is something I'm gonna call big block
sources and moreover these things have
high me entropy also the AMIA entropy is
a K squared over N to the 1.01 something
basically when K is a bit larger than
the root n then you still have a lot of
entropy in your sources okay so if you
if the circuit is sampling something
which has meant to be larger than root n
return then - you still have high
minions with big block sources so bit
block source is a special case we find
source it just needs a string of symbols
so where symbols either fixed bit or
it's literal so 0 1 z 5 it's a uniform
beat 1 minus C 3 is the complement of Z
3 is it really and so on you can think
of these as just a fine sources they're
actually our results we specifically use
the bit block structure but in this talk
you can just think of them as a fine
sources so we know how to build
extractors for these things now
especially especially now much better
than before
so as a corollary of this this theorem I
want to want to show now why circuit
cannot same for improper pairs of the
dysfunction F okay here is the proof
blue proof by conviction assume that the
you could sample this thing in this
thing exactly
then in particularly the mean entropy of
the upper distribution of C is very
large because this thing has me entropy
n okay so the niente plus X will be M so
by this thing here you can write X as a
convex combination this a bit blocked
sources now there is a step that then
I'm just going to hand wave you can
basically fix the bit that correspond to
F of Y here by fixes some bits some some
input bits while living high entropy and
then you're left with a high high
entropy big block source but the value
of F is fixed and that kinetics I didn't
destruct of property
question so yeah
just a heads-up that this thing actually
only gives statistical distance more
than zero but not even 0.1 okay because
this step here if so if cervix was the
closest statistical distance to this
thing here but it's not clear in fact it
sports in general that the mihrab is
large okay and we're gonna have to fix
this fix testing later but for now I
want to fix the value of y and yes with
the condition with the new source still
be big block sauce yes yes you can
because yes so basically would be just
fixed in some this bit so yeah so I'm
even shown this thing in detail but
basically you can fix adjust this
portion because now just is very simple
structure it remains a bit blocky
remains with hand trippin that's
impossible except top property okay so I
want to I want to show you the the proof
of this theorem okay so this is a
characterization of Jaime entropy a c0
sources and the proof is done two steps
in the first step we will do it when the
circuit is actually not the zero but
it's even a blocker so each output bit
will just depends on the input bits and
then there is a way to reduce a zero to
this de local training the way it's done
is via the switch limit we use random
restrictions the switch lemma will
collapse a zero to a de local function
and the new ingredient is that we are
gonna have to guarantee that that that
the entropy is preserved so let's first
see this and so this one slide that with
the proof and I just want to spend a
couple minutes on this also do is I want
to ask you a question just take a deep
breath and so what I am doing so here
are some
from bits okay x1 through some element
here I've my output distributions are n
and bits okay
and this thing is D local where's the
mini means that each output bit here
just depends on the input bits when I'm
trying to show I'm trying to show that
this Apple distribution here the Y's can
actually be written as complex
combinations of this bit block
sources in which you just have these
these blocks of things which are
independent and just and just even don't
know one bit okay behind me entropy okay
so how's the signal so the first step is
that without loss of generality I can
also ask that the degree of the excess
is small so how small wagon Aska it's a
two and D over K so you have D times n
edges in this graph the number of
accesses which has a large has to be
larger than this it is the most secure
to so if you can you can just fix those
decay over to access and because you
have me entropy K that just gonna still
leave you with me entropy K over 2 and
that's and that's good
so I can assume that this degree is
small and now eager quantities so
because the auto v output entropy is
still large is still still Omega K it's
Cuba - now you can show that the sum of
these bits here has to be somewhat
uniform specifically can say that the
variant say that most is at least K over
N because if you easily if you have K
bits of entropy here you have n bits on
them and to have balanced children by in
a super romantic argument if this thing
has a variance well then one these bits
here that are the input of this bit here
must must be somewhat influential so the
influence will be the variance divided
by the interest there's the bit here
what a mess what risk difference
variance is divided by D and so you have
some beaker which inferential is the XJ
here and now the idea the base
do you want this guy to give you a web
block okay so the way it's done is that
you're going to think of sampling the
excess by first sampling the
neighborhood of the neighborhoods of
this xj except xj so this takes a bit to
visualize but i think you've seen today
i so once you this the neighborhood of
this bit here will just depend in this
bit because you fixed anything else and
this thing with the probability that
comes from this influence bond is still
alive means it's still gonna affected
the block okay so that's gonna give you
one block so one bit of a mean entropy
okay and because you fix the things in
this way you've actually you can
actually repeat the argument so you can
iterate you can find another why i now
repeat the judgment you will not have
any interference ability fix in this
neighborhood you don't care about
anything positive that could be shared
okay so okay so we probably probably
which is this inference bound this
neighborhood of xj is one block which is
which is alive of this size okay you you
can repeat a number x which is at the
end to be that you have a divided by how
much stuff here fixing which is the size
of this neighborhood of neighborhood
which you know exactly how to bound
because one thing is the end everything
is this end over k and so you know you
can do it crashing of major entity you
will expect some some number of blocks
okay and you guessing you get some
nominal blocks without probability which
are alive and stable
so this bond is worse than the one that
I had before but you can change its a
bit so one question are like very much
is duties for trees
so is this thing true for the decision
trees so it is true if you use the
switch laminate shit-heap the tree will
officially make it local but that gives
you much worse bounds okay in terms of a
drawer and this is is it true that you
know it be depth tree source can be
decomposed and this way actually many of
the steps here fettered it's all sensor
the more conceptual steps and they go to
so this is still true yes yes we really
see through this a nice work by image
some people here that still gives you an
inferential bits but some of these
technicalities of doing this type of
restrictions here of terms of like
degree that's what it doesn't work and
it's not yes
one I want the same parameters with d3
and I don't know that the HGH fault okay
so that's the question
tree and indeed she will give better
bounds better arrow bombs for the
support assembly advance so we're done
this so it was a bit technical but I
think you've seen how you can decide
about this like local chapters so now to
end all the generalities you wrote
circuits as I mention earlier we're
going to use the random restrictions
this is going to make the circuit clock
up the England here is that I want to
preserve with T entropy okay so and
mainly my here is the lemon that says
that for any function we have any
function or whatsoever on some inputs
that Ibiza was up would distribution as
nyan to decay then if you hit with a no
restriction that leaves each it's be
drive with probability then the
restricted emerge from the function as
in the entropy PK okay that's the best
posture because the function would just
copy the input in the output given to be
PK if your this plus is the switch lemma
you can reduce the zero to local name
they used abused result and you will get
double bond so the proof of this is by
bonding the collision probability of
defeated birch from the function the
misstep in this proof is actually as
something I want to spend a couple of
minutes on is with veronika a nasa
parametric inequality for noise it's
something that appeared in February and
she was used in many of the papers in
this area for some reason and it's this
is this result here so let's say that
you have a set a of them to the Alpha
okay and you pick a uniform input X and
then you pick a noise vector and where H
beta is
we probably pee okay and now you want to
know what's the chance that X is in a
and also the noisy version of X X plus n
is also in a because you have this to
play direct copies so this quantity is
always at least alpha square you can
prove this by cauchy-schwarz that's not
important for us it's always at most
alpha okay just because the chance that
X is in a that most alpha but the
content of this is that we actually gain
a factor of alpha to the P which is
critical for for every one ship this you
can bound the condition probability we
are some norm inequalities which some
nourish oh okay but I want to give you
the proof of this because it's a
two-line proof in in hindsight so here
is the hospital metric statement again
so you have set a x and x + m and the
chance that both chillin DNA that most
alpha to the 1 plus p okay it's supposed
to just alpha this should be good
anymore so that's the proof so let me
actually switch to characteristic
function so let me set f to be the
characteristic function of a okay so
what I need to bound is the expectation
of xn n of the product of f of X and f
of X + n f of X is booyah 0 1 so n will
be just the product product okay so let
me just bring inside the expectation of
range of station over X so f of X times
expectation of n of this and now I'm
good shape for doing Cauchy Schwarz so
this is just the expectation of some a
times B so I can do Cauchy Schwarz and I
get the square root is the most is it
mostly the square root of expectation of
X of F square X okay this is just one
term that's very separate from the rest
the times the square root of the
expectation of X of the square of this
so this expectation over N square this
and now the second step in of this thing
here is the l2 norm of the noisy version
of F so you can apply hyper
contractivity cognitively is the result
which allows you to treat the noise for
the norm so specifically you can relate
this to the the norm of F and the norm a
is not - but it's - - order of P okay so
you V you get you go from l2 norm of the
noisy version of effort to the - - order
P norm of X the first term will remain
same now because F is a boolean the all
these are just 1 so what you get here is
this is the square root of alfalfa's the
density of desert and here you get this
is this is just 1 so you get alpha to
the 1 over 2 - order P and so you get
square root of 2 here and here you get
square alpha plus a little bit from this
and that gives you that
so isn't it just more expansion just
what I think you can view it as a more
said expansion and also split them out
evenly in order to do push this works
so the Duchess it's possible to get
other proof which would be tight for for
sunset which I'm not shown here so you
just just do some free analysis and so
I'm not sure if what you're saying would
be a simple proof than this expansion
for the few busy driver this is partly
tutorial so sorry not me this is like
you know polished already so unlike so
anybody in pitches for the seasonings
right so so he is the recap or where we
are so we show that high entropy zero
sources become high entropy bit block
sources this thing implies sampling over
the bounds but they only give
statistical distance non zero they do
not even give you a constants very
similar distance because it's possible
that the circuit of the age distribution
which has a distance a is 0.1 but the
mini entropy of G of X is constant in
language here let me give you a tool
example the holodeck can happen is a
very very natural example so let me but
see this the circuit say which shown
input X I just call look at the per se
four bits of the input if troll zero is
going to up to the old 0 string and what
is going to sample why for why exactly
okay so now clearly statistical distance
of the solutions this thing from why why
is just at most a 0.1
okay but the entropy is constant okay
because it's
if you just fix it for four bits you get
the fix the output okay so the this this
is why we couldn't get it in the in the
pure sway epsilon I'm trying to overcome
this barrier and push the sampling or
bond or something very close to a half
so the observation here is that however
in this example here if you fix those
four bits then the entropy polarizes it
will become zero or it becomes very
large when the skin is either zero
becomes and and it's possible to show
that this thing happens for every it is
erode circuit that is the general
phenomenon so here is the main
polarizing result that let's could
written and someone will explain why I
have question marks on the slide so I
claim that that for every here circuit
but in some input tool and put bit you
can find a set of restrictions so it's
the may be restrictions that s the
restriction that accomplish two things
the first one is that they preserve the
output distribution by which I mean that
the upper distribution of C over uniform
X is very close to the distribution of
Danis forum you first pick a random R
from s the random restriction are from
this set s then you fill the Stars
random okay Judas so you would just get
distant second attachment like 0.1 and
simultaneously the mean entropy is
polarized mean that for every
restriction in the set solicited to R
has meant to be the zero it's fixed or
Aspen ami Allah
anyone explained the question marks
construct
so let's say for three that the circuit
has an applet which is a uniform over
half the points what was trained with
this
so in the case at least buddy most
Americans say this thing is said trivia
right so well I can just take s to be
one input for every possible output on a
circuit right and this would this will
exactly preserve the APOD distribution
at a realistic free if it's flat and of
course we polarize right then the
circuit is completely fixed the me n2
below this b0 make sense so of course
this just s would be bunch of inputs the
circuit is fixed and the distribution is
exactly preserved the content of the
result that this thing here actually is
not truly am I mean it can be made a
little bit less so it's exponential a -
a polynomial in n now you can do this
thing from before right you can get away
with the server feature which is just
exponential in n - a polynomial in N and
this still gonna preserve the output
distribution is still any sort of per
item entropy so now this thing actually
actual restrictions with some stars so
that will need to be filled otherwise
you cannot do this
so the proof of this result is kinda
like it goes two steps kind of like the
previous one so you may argue for logger
functions and the reduces so and the
template is somewhat similar and I'm
just going to show you through your one
name which again talks about arbitrary
functions not just a zero and it's the
main polarization lemma that I will
discuss so the lemma says that if you
have any function whatsoever then you
can find a set of Furious fictions so
it's the number of numbers which is the
expansion n minus polynomial in N and
the function resemble output and the
properties that dissipation will
preserve the output distribution of the
functions as you mean that the f of X
for you for you from X will be closed in
statistical East and the to - what you
get if you first Sempron are in s and
then you fill the starts a random bunch
of this then do other things and get the
result appreciate okay but I'm just
going to show this and sketch the proof
of this of this result is it the
Clearwater trend yes possibly yes zero
prescriptions so I think I think you'll
get very good at you know yes I'm okay
so let me actually comment on this proof
assume the proof is by a probabilistic
argument which you are going to pick
guess randomly from the set of
restrictions which probably the star say
n to the minus 0.9 okay so the usual
technique and the goal is to show that
so so what we show that if you fix any
any output of F and you look at the
preimage said okay this is sort of some
density alpha you want to show that with
very high probability over the choice of
s okay when you pick a restriction from
s and you feel the starts random what
you get lengths in a will probably very
close to the NCD of alpha so the
probability of S has to be at most to
the minus n the other provided that I
can do in bond over all possible images
and a deviation of this lenny in a also
has to be furniture is more in n because
i need to sum over all possible
contributions of tea sets so one thing
is that actually you cannot show the
distinct clothes you can only show a
lower tail bound but that's the
patientís way if you if for every sector
you bound the lower tail because the
sets form a partition on the space you
can verify that you did each set would
be close but the important thing is that
the deviation here is exponentially
small in n but the number of samples is
less than through the n so we are we
need to handle a deviation which is
smaller than the one then the number of
samples okay and this requires an
argument so the idea here is that the
first thing that you need to show that
that this quantity here has more
variance okay so it is sum of variables
with small variance and the small
variance here is done via NASA
barometric inequality like the one that
I showed before and then you need to use
a specific concentration of measure
result which is a tail order for small
variance
distribution and these bounds actually
are so the apathy of what should be
false so if so usually doesn't matter if
you do a birthday run over Taylor so in
this case actually in the effort they
will be false
only the lower tales known for these
things about it but that's enough in our
setting okay okay that's that's a sketch
I don't know so the upper button the
upper tail is what's on the Berenstain
result the birds name it has an extra
factor in the exponent which will make
this thing useless the corresponding
lower tail which are no last name it
does not have the text Roboto and can be
used here you can afford to take our
asses of this looks nice
maybe as a way of arguing with your sin
just be called all of them will be fixed
they will you fix nominal format is the
number of successes of this number yes
I don't know yeah I don't know that I'm
sure that that would simplify
I'm just think the description of s is
it important that it's a random subset
of this size of all restrictions that
live in point nine alive or is really
all of them but the mesosphere whether
it's all of them or just almost all so I
mean how many efficient I mean there is
this number times this is a number
viable six times and choose end point so
okay
only to think of that yeah
for the
yeah
we can take it offline okay so so I'm
just putting said real in immuno so in
en de with problem bound for for
sampling is why Hawaii distribution
where F is a bit block a lot or I just
want to flesh
how do witnesses receive a distance so
so if you give me a circuit see denied
she will do so that the statisticalist
and the future is very close to half so
the type of test here that will give the
system's is of the form a young B so a
would be the set of those few
restrictions that make the circuit
constant they give the zero the entropy
that was guaranteed in the previous
lemma and B is Mitch just checks that
this fo is computed correctly just
repairs YB would be different from him
it gave for why basically so if you
think of this up with the distribution
of that circuit you're gonna think of it
as first sampling in our in s and then
Tina starts at random so when you picker
if the circuit is constant and is always
going to lend the innate but the target
is this solution is likely to land in
eight because it is more and targeted
solutions rather than should be another
wise Co are as relevant to be and
they've used the previous result so the
Tago test in the end at the guaranteed
these things are of this type and you
can actually get away with without once
- because you just have eight and the
circuit would just have put the
something which lines there if you just
a bit actually you will not get the
statistical distance so that say you
want okay so there's many problems like
the ones that I mentioned just two more
so one thing is to improve the service
you listen to it exponentially close to
half it would be nice to I think you
also to Jeremiah central reported issues
attribute somehow
because that especially this restriction
that it would have some consequences for
how many put beats the circuits require
the sample distill this dissolution in
general I think and there's more to
being works in more general settings not
only AC zero whenever some people I can
do with station simplify yes so it's
false
4:08 party aids and so yes so yeah so
you yes so it okay good so yes it's an
interesting question whether you
calculate this this type of results to
like the shrinkage exponent and I think
so the previous result about the worst
case sampling or bound that can be
extended to shrinkage I thinks I think
this entropy pair additional I was not
able to do that because there was not
cool enough to measure something to but
but in general if I can extend the
session so I think you can think of
getting any model that you're I could
that'd be sorry here and try to think of
what it means I mean we've been doing
that right we started with work or
sketch and then the people doing average
case so what also not do something or
bounce for you know you know what you
know formulas that potential circuits
and so on
in the 50s people of polarization what
you use the fact that it senses a virtue
so I am not so this land my tree this
image shows the for every function so so
as I met as I mentioned in passing so
for the general result so this thing is
proved in step-touch which I've not
shown but basically once you have a
function with small locality then you
can do it in a similar speed of water
shredder so you stop like fixing things
and counting things how much on through
so that's kind of like easy to
understand so I had to reduce I see zero
circuit or something like that something
the locals let's and be a random
restrictions so the restriction I mean
the serum sells for it every civil
service whether they use DAC or
something so this thing is the things I
found so first you prove it for safety
local functions okay and then you go
from a zero to those things and there
the way to this use given angle
restriction I use this switch ulema then
use the position to argue that you can
switch them and we just with
restrictions that don't change the
output distribution the polar ah so such
a yeah so this predation is really only
done at the local level then for the
zero you just you find this very sparse
hell restrictions which go from zero to
D logger which reserved the distribution
and then you can polarize below
[Applause]